so how does that how does that like I'm
just trying to think a day in the life
of you homeschooling like the night
before you teach yourself whatever the
lesson is and then you teach it to your
kids is that how it works I don't know
sorry if this is a dumb question I just
don't know everybody has a different
style but the way I do it is we kind of
just go along and then if I'm like H I
don't know what this is I'm like okay
and then I'll show the kids if we don't
know this how do we find the answer how
do you look something up and make sure
that it's a good source that you're
getting the information from how do you
figure out something you don't know
where do you go to look for information
so you're kind of teaching them how to
teach themselves rather than just spoon
feeding them information and we rarely
spend more than like 1 to two hours a
day because you can be so efficient and
you can be so targeted in what you're
doing where when you think about it and
you're you're in a public school for 7
hours how much of the seven hours are
you learning